After a century of striving,...
...after a year of debate, after a historic vote,...
...health care reform is no longer an unmet promise. It is the law of the land.
It is the law of the land.
And although it may be my signature that's affixed to the bottom of this bill,...
...it was your work, your commitment,...
...your unyielding hope that made this victory possible.
When the special interests deployed an army of lobbyists,...
...an onslaught of negative ads...
...to preserve the status quo. You didn't give up.
You hit the phones and you took to the streets.
You mobilized and you organized.
You turned up the pressure and you kept up the fight.
When the pundits were obsessing over who was up and who was down,...
...you never lost sight of what was right and what was wrong.
You knew this wasn't about the fortunes of a party; this was about the future of our country.
And when the opposition said, this just wasn't the right time,...
...you didn't wanna wait another year or another decade,...
...or another generation for reform. You felt the fierce urgency of now.
You met the lies with truth. You met cynicism with conviction.
Most of all, you met fear with a force that's a lot more powerful...
...and that is faith in America. You met it with hope.